and time again everyone seems to bring a
new idea about how to close it with
initiatives announced on business
transport housing or skills and this
month is no different with home
secretary Priti Patel promising that as
part of a new purse brexit world
immigration rules will change to a
points-based system but get this as part
of the system if people agree to live up
north they're gonna get extra points
supposedly this will help spread the
benefits of immigration more evenly and
make sure people don't just settle in
London when they come here but plans
devised in Westminster are often
contradictory to the once needs and
desires of the north and now of course
I'm all for trying to fix the divide but
please can we do it properly with things
like improved education further
devolution proper transport and with
proper consultation of those who
actually live there so so one way of
reading what you just said that the
Australian points based system I think
there are some doubts about that to
whether it actually works not because
actually one of the concerns with it is
that you end up with highly highly
skilled migrants who are unable to get
beyond the gig economy unable to get the
work that they qualified for so there
whatever but they're effectively not
doing the work that they're qualified
for so they're putting those concerns to
one side I do worry that and I agree
with you that your point about if the
infrastructure isn't built to deal with
this education schools hospitals then
we're just going to repeat more on the
same which is if we're encouraging
migrants to go up north we're already
there is a north-south economic divide
and there's poverty and we're set and
we're asking migrants to go there if the
infrastructure isn't there to support
them you were only going to stoke more
tensions you're going to create more
divisions you're going to put more of a
strain on that infrastructure and it may
not fix the problems you intend to fix
so I think it is a it's a it's a good
idea to encourage economic migration
from the south to the north but without
necessary investment infrastructure
investment done first and properly and
taken seriously because for me you know
of course this is all fine and well and
good but I just feel like it's constant
tinkering around the edges and constant
you know sound bites as to what we will
do and it's not ever taken seriously
enough for me there's proper north/south
devised what do you think yeah no I
totally see what you're saying and I
agree with what magazine as well I think
I've always thought that immigration
needs to be somehow better spread around
the whole of the country and that way
you don't get the sorts of resentments
from the sort of indigenous communities
that you've seen in certain areas like
like the community that I grew up in but
the problem is often what happens is
with with immigrants when I think of my
family you settle where there are people
you know so if there is a large cluster
of a certain immigrant group then more
people settle there and I think that
what needs to happen is we need some
sort of program as well as the
infrastructure development and so on we
need something that actually prepares
the local community for this new group
that's coming in so that there's a
better way of integrating them that's
what we've never done properly I would
say probably we did it well with him
with the wind rush because we had all
those videos of you know the sort of
Caribbean people coming over and there's
a little bit of a sort of excitement
almost we've never done it since it's
easier to integrate the first few that
come yeah by definition yes exactly the
minute you have a community and people
are tempted that's where it becomes
harder to to have the mixing we need to
figure out the integration piece and
where were we all born I was born in
London where are you born
London Essex oh wow so in a way Michelle
what you're you're here in London
working in London and so what you're
your presence here in a way explains the
problem did you've migrated south
because this is where the opportunities
only this is where you want to be this
is where you want to live this way you
want to work now where I would want to
live and work is home in hole oh yeah
and the opportunities
magnet for other people like weird or
rush up and we'd talk about economic
migration you look at things like
Westminster having this humungous
refurbishment for I think it's six years
or so what I would do is actually
relocate Parliament for that for those
six years to than are parts of Europe
and they has no substance it can't work
this part of the Australian system has
been proven everybody at one point was
taken to Perth because sorry in the
outskirts of person all exactly the same
thing would happen you need a community
you need the hospital's unit so there we
remove them all to Sheffield and Harlem
wherever else and Blackburn and
understandably many of them what just
comes up it cannot work period strange
fair when I suggested during that six
year period of refurb that you could
relocate Parliament ignore if you did
regional assemblies I don't know the
cost of the country's got a lot of Merit
I don't know should just be you should
probably go to the east miss politicians
experience life should do the whole
country Michelle you shouldn't just be
because you'll just create the same
you'll just have people angry in the
southwest well why doesn't it come to
door normal or even Devon and Cornwall
we moved Parliament and and I agree with
your idea about even if we did that it
doesn't address the integration problem
in two separate kind of communities in
the same city sixty percent of migrants
who settled in rural areas then left the
rural areas within five years but I
would argue it's because of this
integration race they probably didn't
feel welcome so we need to figure that
bit out well it's interesting to me
because we don't have the problem that
Paris has in that it's only wealthy
people and poor people on the suburbs
and the outskirts but we even though
we're living in London Granville Tower
was in the Royal Borough of Kensington
and Chelsea the thing is we're still
living very separate lives even if we're
next door to each other yeah I don't see
us mixing in there there was a one of my
son's schoolteachers was her 15 year old
mentioned this before was tragically
stabbed to death and my wife went to the
church for the funeral I was at work I
couldn't go but she went and she's
American white and she came back and she
was astonished because it's in the same
area we live the church is literally on
the same street we it's a five minute
walk to that church she was astonished
at the separate lives that people are
living in the same neighborhood on the
same street it's on the same street
different separate lives completely and
she went into that service in that
church and she said she was she said
she's probably the only white person
there and so what does that tell us
about this idea from the government then
you think that that would just create
the same with I'm interested in June's
point how do we get people to how is it
that my wife was the only white person
at this funeral when we're living on the
same street on that no you're watching
the pledge on Sky News next why no one
is too cool for school
[Music]